so terry what was your aha moment
i know that you said you didn't want to
lose her but
what was it for you i'm gonna be
perfectly honest here when the marriage
was over
i was like okay that's it then i'm done
and but a little voice told me
that it was everyone else everyone else
was my issue
and it changed when it really really
cracked the egg that said
this is me and i called a friend and he
was my counselor
and my pastor and he said he said terry
i can't
tell you you're gonna get your wife back
your wife is probably gone forever
but you need to get better for you now
you gotta understand
for a man that was a watershed moment
for me
i always did good things to get you know
you get
cookies so to speak you always you work
out so you can look like this
you do nice things so you can get sex
you
go to work so you can get money wait a
minute so you can get the girl
yeah you know just actually improving
myself
just to improve that was like wait a
minute he said hey man
this is about you because you're
probably going to be alone and you still
are going to be stuck in your problem
and i realized listen i didn't even go
to rehab to get her back
but what happened was while i was fixing
myself
we reunited and it just
it became a now it could have went the
other way that's still
rebecca's choice it was always rebecca's
choice whether
she wanted to be here or not so yes and
there were many times drew that
hey i kept playing tickets in my hand
but i'm thankful i i was laying in bed
last night
playing this song i love called grateful
and all i was thinking was how grateful
i
am that i still have terry i mean
i really appreciate this conversation
but you have your children this is all
out there
where do they fall into that now that
the cat's out of the bag
yes well you know part of our counseling
and one of the things that our
counselors told us to do was to actually
talk to each one of our kids
and explain it at their level and we
want to make sure that
they that they knew that this was not
about them this was not their issue this
is something
daddy and mommy are working through
right and this is a 12-step model
that's used with sex addiction so it
deals with
um you know talking to the victims of
your behavior
yeah and that included our children yeah
okay
on a last note i just want to say you
guys
have brought a lot of joy and levity
and honesty in all of this and
how do you guys laugh how do you guys
just kick all the bags lighten up
keep it real have a good time how do you
do it
well he's he's a bag of jokes every
single day
my husband brings the fun and i bring
the structure i always say
we joke a lot we make fun of each other
generally we just like each other and
i even said to him i said even if you
left me and married someone else
i'd still be your best friend because i
know you better than anyone
else now she's not getting everything i
work for though
that's the humor i'm talking about and
we all need it to
survive terry and rebecca
i am so grateful for this conversation
and um i applaud your guys's choice
and i just think you're awesome thank
you so much rebecca and terry
wow thank you so much um stronger
together
the audio only memoir by terry cruz and
rebecca king cruz
is available now exclusively on audible
what a powerhouse thank you so much you
guys thank you so much
you